you know who would be mortified by your
Instagram feed Christopher Columbus that
guy wouldn't heart anything because the
world isn't flat like all these photos
that's why you've got to spice up your
feed with some 360 degree photos and
what some call tiny planet photos huh
starting to get nauseous there for a
second
a Pete's miracle photos are really fun
and they're starting to pop up more and
more so how do you make them well there
are a couple of ways let's start with
the more expensive though higher quality
option this 360 degree $300
Ricoh theta camera the fisheye lenses on
each side of the camera captures a
hundred and eighty degrees of your
surroundings then it stitches it all
together then you get the app connect
the camera to your phone and view the
images and even pan around them you can
share one of those photos through
Facebook or Twitter and then your
friends will be taken to a link where
they can actually pan around the photos
the best way to actually share your tiny
planet on Instagram is to zoom out on
the photo and get it just right and then
take a screenshot option two is about
three hundred dollars cheaper yep you
can use your iPhone or your Android
phones camera and get a special app for
the iPhone out of the five I tested I
like the $2 circular the best you can
take the photo through the app or import
any photo outdoor shots with some sky or
the best the app then rolls it up lets
you zoom edit and add some fun effects
you can't manipulate the images like you
can with the Ricoh they can still fake
some really cool shots for Android and
app called tiny planets effects does a
lot of the same things what are you
still doing here on my tiny planet go
take some of your own and share them I
can't promise this guy will like them
but someone will
you